here now with reaction south carolina
senator lindsey graham senator
i i never thought in less than 18 months
that you could destroy
the best economy in the world that you
would abandon americans in afghanistan
that war would break out in europe and
he would have a ho-hum attitude about
the whole thing and not immediately see
the urgency to help ukraine win the war
fast they would have had we provided the
equipment early we didn't do it uh and
now we're out of baby formula and his
answer is go talk to your ob gyn doctor
and ask if they have any samples in the
office
really
right well
really so his policies biden's policies
are dumb and dangerous they're not
working it's dumb and dangerous what
they're doing at the border it's dumb
and dangerous to stop producing american
oil and gas to go from energy
independence to dependence the question
for us is how do you fix it
biden's never going to change unless
somebody makes it the only reason he got
more involved in ukraine is because you
and i and others kicked his ass every
night saying that you're letting putin
win you're betting on putin winning how
about betting on your train winning for
a change so i i think the republican
party owes it to the american people not
to just describe the problem but to fix
it let's come up with a border security
plan like president trump had let's come
up with an energy independence plan put
it on the table and start talking about
it to give the american people some hope
with all due respect we had a plan stay
in mexico build the wall vet people
coming into the country we had a plan we
opened up energy exploration everywhere
and we became energy independent and a
net exporter of energy uh build the
keystone xl pipeline and stop giving
waivers to your buddy vladimir putin you
know simple things like that right and
don't abandon americans behind enemy
lines
well what trump did worked on the border
what he did on energy independence work
what he did to kill
isis work what he did to get the arabs
and the israelis working together was
successful he was strong in the face of
iranian aggression but the point i'm
trying to make we're about to go into
election six months from now every night
i'll listen to your show and i get
depressed about the state of america i
want to hear on your show how we fix
this
we know what works but let's put it in
writing i'm begging the leadership of
the republican party led by donald trump
to come out with solutions to a broken
border how to become energy independent
again how to regain control of the
supply chain and how to make the world
safer place
yeah i want the same thing senator this
is an all hands on deck moment this this
race in november for republicans not to
take back the senate not to take over
the house
allows this radical agenda to continue
we can stop it right in its tracks and
then in 2024 begin the process of
undoing the damage he's done it's that
critical to the country and our future
in my opinion thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else